you go to the same cocktail parties that
the State Department officers go to and
then a dinner party after the cocktail
party but in between you go meet an
agent and you pay him off and you get a
receipt and you rush up to the embassy
and stow the stuff so it won't fall out
of your pocket at the dinner party or
something and then you go to the dinner
party and then after the dinner party
you go run another errand and this goes
on day in and day out Saturdays Sundays
holidays and when you begin to see that
the organization as a whole is very
sloppy and poorly run and the standards
are very low you're it's hard to stay
motivated it's hard to keep thinking
it's worth five and you really get to a
state where you just just really don't
want to have to lock everything about
your professional life and a safe and
lie to all of the people you know about
who you really are and what you're
really doing what your real dreams and
aspirations and promotions are and be
able to complain to them about your
failures or our problems well I realize
now that the business of the CIA is to
go out and to corrupt individuals in
their in place in their own countries
and that this is something that corrupts
oneself this was going against his
upbringing which was a strong Christian
very moral background and he was coming
into conflict with himself hating
himself angry with himself you know I
would like to present myself as a man of
intense principle who saw bad things and
immediately resigned and discussed but
my career was obviously going quite well
I had the prestige of people coming to
me for jobs coming to me for advice
inviting me to lunch wanting to play
tennis with me this is you know
obviously a human satisfaction I was not
yet in top management I couldn't really
give away a lot of jobs but I could
speak on the behalf of someone my income
was about $33,000 a year and ten years I
could retire
$21,000 a year pension for the rest of
my life I had total security was it
thought that you would be continuing to
do things like the Vietnam involvement
angle and the angle and involvement the
thought was immoral or counterproductive
waste well what I tried to do was to
psych myself into going back to Africa
as a chief of station in someplace like
cartoon for example which would have
been a nice post for my grade and just
not push covert operations very much if
something came along it was just sort of
irresistible some agent that just had to
be recruited will let an officer in my
station recruiting but basically just
play a lot of tennis and let the
paychecks come in this is traditionally
what burned out senior case officers do
and I'm muddled and waffled and
vacillated and rationalized for about
eight months before I could tear myself
away I I don't really look at it as
taking that much guts to quit I just
sort of didn't have any choice by
November and December I had intense
pains in my abdomen which were obviously
the precursors of a stomach ulcer from
the internal conflict of wanting to hang
on to this career but not respecting it
I had requested many times that Bob just
drop out of the CIA just get out and
start life in you someplace he wasn't
able to do so when I asked him to but
now he has he seen even more since our
divorce and yes I do feel vindicated
when a man comes back and says he were
right all along everything you ever said
was right everything you ever said about
everybody who walked into our house was
right what lesson did you learn from
your dad's experience well of course
brings up values just all over the place
and that that any I could go
break up on that a whole lot but yawn
listening to him right now I'm writing
it well what's your reaction to CIA memo
I think up hi there slobs and then
you're down in the lower when you get
down into the on people actually out in
the field and they would do working you
know likes me a very inefficient crooked
really sloppy organization I was not a
man at peace with himself and since I
resigned I do not feel in a position of
conflict I feel in a position of being
peace with myself morally